flickering monitors and dark rooms
gamers in their element but these gamers
are playing for more than just points
they're playing for charity
bashir bo maza a pro gamer from belgium
launched gaming for good two years ago
he's already raised more than 21 million
euros for worthy causes gaming is really
crucial because that is what a lot of
young people love to do and it's their
passion and since gaming is one of the
biggest entertainment industries and
really focuses on a very young target
audience I thought it was an amazing way
to just reach out a very big audience
and inspire people to just you know like
give back bashe abu mosa AKA Athene is a
star on the gaming scene he's ranked
among the best gamers in the world and
has more than 700,000 followers on
YouTube his website features some 100
video games all donated by their
manufacturers to play you have to make a
donation the contributions go directly
towards funding charity projects
the entire internet generation to put it
our ways it's much better informed and
since we're all more connected we also
feel more empathy to help others so I
think yeah the gaming the gaming
platform is one of one of the most
powerful to it to just reach people and
to also make people more active minded
and actually try and make a difference
ishiba maza also makes personal
appearances to generate publicity for
his project he wants the gaming
community to become more aware of social
and political issues with a video camera
in tow he's traveled to developing
countries and regions in crisis he's
visited both Ethiopia and Liberia
documenting what happens with the
donated funds he also involves his fans
directly for example donors were able to
submit questions to Ebola survivors in
Liberia boom ozs work is also helping to
boost the gaming scenes image
gamers generally they often get a bad
rap so people think that they're violent
or they're strange or you know they're
different gaming for good and charity
events give them a greater sense of
pride because they feel much more
involved in the world gaming for good
has become a trend and Bashir blue Mazda
has found supporters around the globe
the potential market for their charity
work is enormous in 2014 the video game
industry had a turnover of about seventy
three billion euros the community of
gamers is rising rapidly the way we
engage with our audience in the way
we're actually bringing the problems
much closer really yeah like really
makes them much more yeah involved and
much more willing to help and it's
because they want to it's not because
just because we are all gamers but it's
also because they actually truly care
else we wouldn't have been able to raise
21 million dollars these days Bashir
boom aza has little time for gaming
instead of collecting points he's
gathering donations
shift says gaming at its best